I just move watch this move watch this
question what's his body weight Oh would
you would you would you know y'all
didn't know that
akin dismember they wouldn't let me in
hey what's going on YouTube okay so
let's just go ahead and cut to the chase
there's been a question or a lot of
questions that's been floating around
this topic
there's a YouTube I don't know what's an
algorithm change if you guys notice for
this past year I've been experimenting
with my channel a lot now with
experimenting with my channel I decided
to just go you know free ball it is a
free ball you just cut a freestyle with
it just upload video see what happens
seeing people like it don't really check
the views and kind of go on with your
life and just be a really good content
creator I've been getting a lot of
comments asking me yo David what's going
on with your views they wouldn't would
you have an opinion about these these
algorithm changes now for me I no idea
what this was I don't know what this
algorithm change was so I decided to go
ahead and look at the past like few
videos in the last couple months and see
how they were doing and wow the views
were [ __ ] okay usually when this happens
if your views drop out of nowhere
because you haven't really been posting
content you haven't been interacting
with your fans but for me that really
wasn't the case so I started doing a
little research here and there and
apparently it's not just me that notices
this or noticed this everybody else did
there was a huge youtuber named
PewDiePie you guys know him that the
gamer really cool dude talking about
what happened to his channel too now
obviously with his channel you know he
went from a few million down to another
few million [ __ ] [ __ ] but for me it's
a big attraction
I went from roughly about averaging like
200,000 to 300 to 400 thousand to
floating around 90 K to 100k now that's
very unheard of of my channel and then I
started reading through my messages
where people were telling me like y'all
I've been unsubscribe to your channel
how come you haven't posted a video in
months you know I'm not getting updates
I'm like yo what the [ __ ]
Wow [ __ ] okay I'll be right back my
stomach is killing me there's a [ __ ]
fire oh my god hold on I gotta turn this
off though I'm back I almost died
I literally [ __ ] out of the lower
intestine and I sent a spirit YouTube
has done these algorithm changes before
it affected our views before which is
why you see a lot of content creators
who started you know doing like double
uploads to make up for the income that
they lost now the first time it happened
I was kind of like hey my views dropped
like 30 or 40 K views per video I was
like oh you know what I'll go ahead and
make that up which I did this time about
forty to fifty percent of my views have
dropped what the [ __ ] that's a lot so
get if like forty percent of my views
disappear obviously that's like forty to
fifty percent of my income that
disappears as well I'm not saying that
I'm gonna go back to selling crack and
sucking dick but if I have two big boys
don't cry [ __ ] it is what it is
hopefully YouTube you guys are going to
fix this or what you guys can do if you
want to help me out if you haven't seen
my videos in a while and you're just
scanning by it or skimming through it
it's that little notification though is
so sad that we as creators have to ask
you to do that hey if you guys want to
watch the videos and you subscribe to
that you guys really do want to see [ __ ]
all the other related ones just make
sure you hit that little Bell so you see
me do my gin when you to does these
changes they don't let us the creators
know you guys don't give us a [ __ ]
heads up that's the [ __ ] problem and
giving us a you know wake up one day and
say hey you know what guys I'm just
gonna [ __ ] you over and give me a heads
up then I would have known I would have
gotten up put on my pants walked outside
hit the street with my high heels and
you know but for those of you who have
been subscribed stay subscribed and made
sure that you came to the channel even
when you didn't get notifications thank
you very much you guys are those 92 or
3,000 views that are keeping me alive so
thank you thank you so much for that
here's another announcement by the way
which probably isn't that smart starting
next year I will be going back to doing
one video a week and let me explain why
when you have somebody who is a content
creator do multiple videos a week for me
the type of content that I create
doesn't allow for that I don't want to
create content that's very duplicitous
or that you could do in an instant
because number one I just it's not for
me I didn't get on this space so I could
be the most famous person in the world I
did it because this is where my heart
was I just love making people laugh I
love entertaining people and that's
where I have to do it
because if I don't do it that way I'm
not going to be able to last on this
platform you know these are the type of
things that I like and when I'm forced
to do content on the regular about to
three times a week blogs with the
lighting is [ __ ] I don't know where I'm
doing it that the content isn't that
great and that part kills me on the
inside so I'm gonna go back to doing one
video a week I'm not saying you won't
get two to three videos if I do it's
only because I want to but Sundays at 12
p.m. that's where you're gonna see my
video love you guys from the bottom of
my heart
2017 is gonna be a crazy year a Gupta
film got into Sundance so in January I
will be going to Sundance to premiere
this movie on the category of I believe
it's called next I am super excited that
is where a lot of my time and attention
went to this year and next year - I'm
gonna be that much more busy Sundays at
12 p.m. remember Sunday that's what we
have studied at 12 p.m. don't make me
sing for it
we even long gather mm-hmm
yeah yeah yeah you [ __ ] wet huh oh
your dicks hard I don't know
[Music]
you
[Music]